hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space 2 okay
we just rocketed out of the sky and fell
through a freaking roof and then landed
so badass into what look kind of looks
like the elementary school again but
fine finally a story how does she know
we're him did she know that I fell
through the sky to save her also oh good
I can sell these it sells for as much as
a ruby semiconductor but I don't think I
want to sell it just yet I'll keep it in
my safe just in case I need a plasma
cutter ammo line racks and javelins I
mean oh there were javelins over in the
other
javelins go quick I thought I had a lot
of ammo but then it just like gone
instantly okay I hear a lot of monsters
I should probably hurry or something
okay um okay a javelin
I was wondering
now
I went around spire okay that should be
enough of that line racks loved design
racks and I'm good on those I could do
this job javelins are chief
I know expenses hell jeez how am i doing
on that
all right animals good I'm guessing I'm
gonna have to fight a bunch of these air
hose out of here so I'm all set to go on
that oh yeah story in a safe point and
lots of enemies in the distance I'm
pretty sure they mean to crunch my bones
I got my marrow
no on my face
goody fine rack you say we came in more
than one page of trash can you moving
honor
let me start out with some lines oh
hello
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
go oh this is where I stand off me ah no
that's so funny that you think you can
take me womp
okay you get friends do America days you
too nope nope
ah doesn't that matter I thought it was
a javelin that's all I was trying to alt
fire oh I'm stupid stupid alright that
was all wasted time I was gonna lay out
traps with the detonator that's why I
had it out but I forgot to do that
shut up lady I'm busy
Kimmy inventory is full Todd I need more
now I'm not getting wine right
upsie with the platform right now
Hey what was that a bag of the face or
trashcan womp yeah they're real womp
womp is so easy the CC door in your
level thanks for that
hurry well I got things in my face shut
up guy guy get dead so pro I don't know
working Wow where'd you come from
came from the darkness there you go good
days I I saw something on out some of
those spitter kilometers doodads
oh come on I just shut off your arm like
10 but Julian times there we go
finally I it's a little one oh what's
that oh what a [ __ ] wonk wonk wonk wonk
wonk pro pro yeah you busted too pro for
all of you womp
with your leg how do you like that
nozzle ah ah you saliva no not today
go let it go I'll go when I'm ready yes
I can't shut up
I need to get the goodies
[Music]
okay I'm in Hey
oh the CC is the company that employed
Isaac before he went hey baby watch your
mouth young lady I was right here this
morning with a crew of 30 people we were
overrun
and before I knew it that transformed I
had some legs off my friends just to
escape I've just walked one big [ __ ]
circle today watch your mouth Yeah right
there's a central hub in the main
facility here the coordinates
Isaak is like crazy cause there's like
me like I would be in this in the face
of adversity like this just yeah I know
I know baby I've been through the same
thing after eight Wow the chattin
seriously the first five six chapters
four five chapters were like boom boom
bah boo boo boo and then all the sudden
is like womp COO chunk or do so I'm just
starting from Chapter II now wow these
are definitely getting
can I do anything about that
other guns do they need the loading he's
a lot of plasma plasma cutter it's
really just a reliable gun reliable as
all get-out cheap ammo it drops
everywhere still rofo are these the
pieces of your friends
hold it together Isaac no going crazy
just yet you know I'm not allowed to go
crazy on my watch
no no no you can only go crazy when I go
crazy and I'm not crazy am I
all teams this is Caleb
Seto geologist from Langford shift 1
there's something in the facility
[Music]
shoot them shoot them now but they're my
friends I think Isaac murdered every
single one of his friends on the
Ishimura Vick whoops she can deal
where am I even going good the debt Oh
Nate all because that's safe always
proved safe for me I've killed myself
more with the detonator than I have with
then any enemies have tried to kill me
oh this isn't look like it worked out
for you yet Oh par note
who wants them ha
who's playing violins
I mean come on I'm a Isaacson
engineering exactly like a super soldier
hey shouldn't shouldn't shouldn't Oh
partner give it was awful nice them they
gave me a partner right there and then
apparently there's like no way that and
there's a power node in here vintage
really
ah the trap
[Applause]
[Music]
okay now there are two targets
that's great null but it's still extract
music I know it's dramatic
as it did to trap I know I want the
schematic not a med pack are you kidding
me
you really think I'd pick up what the
house put out the trap aw come on
seriously
and now I've got too much ammo all these
goodies are gonna work waste and it
won't let me pick up the freakin
[Music]
why is there something out here oh
that's what it is and you're not dead
are you good oh you son-of up are you
kidding me here they are
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm bad at this game aren't I I'm just
bad at it aren't it I just suck shut up
you bad yeah you're making
geez how many are in there gotta be
kidding me all right I gotta clean about
frickin crackle then I'll come back for
this
oh come on no stop it you I swear come
on okay where are they screw this screw
this I placed it like now umpteen health
packs it's crap much as I love this
detonator
it gets me killed on now I only get one
power know there's repair nodes in here
dammit
whatever let me just go see what the
hell the vintage suit is all about
[Music]
spork the rusty what else
gah space Vantage suit items at the
store just kind of 10 percent 20
inventory slots and 50% armor holy hell
yeah I need to sell something to get
that but I don't care
sell it grit pang I'm gonna keep paying
but 20 slots yes please
i'ma bring it out I miss the old system
where you just had the suit and you
upgraded it I kind of like that a bit
maybe feel spec what I guess it is
vintage I just picked up the crappiest
suit possible
oh god I look like a firefighter
whatever it don't matter is long he's
got the inventory I don't care all right
that's all the time I got for this
episode actually went way over but thank
you guys so much for watching
sorry about the rage and I will see you
in the next part
bye bye